let's talk roses that's right it's day
four of our rose test we have five
bouquets here heathers we're getting
ready for valentine's day to see what
might be the best to buy for your loved
ones five flower shops nate joining us
today because uh you're gonna be like
drew carr you don't look like drew carey
but you're gonna be prices right exactly
okay i do not i am not drew carey so the
prices range from under 20 okay over 130
you heather and john take these prices
and you put them on the bouquets that
you think they apply to 86
we have 96 dollars and we have 102
i'm going with the 19 on that because i
think it's from trader joe's because i
think it's you more unique 96
86 is here i'm putting this one right in
the front oh
yeah i agree and 102. okay so we'll go
and i'm gonna come up they're still
alive and 96 because those are those are
not so good and to be clear just so you
know two of these are from local shops
two are from online
yeah so we are not going to reveal which
shop is which but do we have time to go
ahead and reveal whether you guys were
right or not
okey doke so
the 19 and 80 cents
that's correct i'm not telling you where
it came from i'm telling you that the
price is correct okay okay so the next
one
that is incorrect
okay so that is going to be this one
right here this is the 96 one
and then i'll take that so you guys
thought this was the most expensive it
is not this is the 86 dollar so one for
three oh man
you're one for five
however
it's not going to be until tomorrow that
we let you guys know which of these
bouquets come from which shop but you
have under 20 bucks to a hundred and
thirty dollars
how much fun is this playing the prices
oh my gosh these what's up these roses
we're gonna try to water and we're gonna
try to bring them back to life do you
think they can come back to life we can
try anyway all right so one for five on
the roses oh man all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna take that one so where are the
five flowers i think we had the slide up
there for just a second we did there's
trader joe's there's pro flowers there's
1 800 flowers and there's two shops here
in town that we've got them all from so
that's where they're from we'll tell you
we'll put the prices with the shops
coming up tomorrow on the eight news now
rose test this is kind of shocking
though a hundred and thirty dollars to
under twenty dollars yeah well you get
what you pay for eight all right for
more rose testing later on this week
sherry let's get over to you in the
weather forecast sherry good morning it
just goes to show you cannot judge a
rose's price by its perky petals